the offseason is over the season begins
now you've been patiently waiting and
we're BAC Kaiba back on the season and I
took so much crap from Eagles fans this
weekend that I'm doing good fishel
podcast in an Eagles Jersey
not just any Eagles Jersey this is the
Eagles Jersey I wore during the
Superbowl I haven't touched it since
it's been on a hanger in my closet for
the last how many months it's a great
Jersey what it what is the numbers made
of snakes getting some of us it's not
authentic it's a bougie Jersey at the
Mall of America I got it for fur you
don't fill it out like be docked it I'll
tell you that much you have a lot of
announcements I'm gonna give you the
guest in a second but first the NFL
season starting and brands want a part
of Sims and left company so let's do a
little bit of pay that man his money I
want to get checks are you ready for
life football on your phone Sims if you
can give me a 1 through 10 on how I do
in this address I don't worry I'm gonna
be harshly grading you are you ready for
live football and your phone well with
the Yahoo Sports mobile I like Yahoo
keep going you got it watch local and
primetime NFL games on your phone or
tablet all season long never miss your
local game never miss a big national
matchup all you need is the Yahoo Sports
app get the Yahoo Sports mobile app and
you are golden ooh
10 I'm gonna cut you off there I mean
anybody can read and good yes yes when
the Simpsons talk about a dumb coach
they go are gonna be able to get on the
field
break the huddle no 1 through 10 what
you think no I was like it was a 9
ok well that's pretty good I thought I
was great myself I'd give it a 7 yeah a
little confident I'm a frequent yeah
whoo news yeah I do it just gives me a
nice roundabout I did my draft on Yahoo
last night Wow yeah no okay yeah too
much think we got they got more than
four there a lot of announcements show
wise Simza left go
wise and guess wise I'm gonna start off
big Sims and left go universe stuff yes
number one we crossed over ten thousand
followers on Instagram
pretty awesome thank you everyone that
follows we're gonna be putting a lot of
content on the Instagram all throughout
the season spend jerk and I have come up
with a plan stuff for Sunday during the
games all throughout the week it'll be
good Sims left code number two you can
now listen to Sims and left go the
podcast on Spotify Spotify our logo that
green and black fits perfectly Spotify
go back so check us out I didn't know I
don't have you know what it is I just
downloaded the reddit app just because
of you yeah a I was trying to explain it
to my wife what reddit is how'd you say
I was just like it's this universe of
different you can find different things
and find your niche of like no matter
what it is even if you like designer
you're gonna be able to find these
people and and be able to community I
don't know what I said
stupid like that I wasn't that impressed
when I opened up the app it's not meant
to be impressed it's not reddit is
actually impressive and how unimpressive
it okay
that's and I did not know that that guy
married Serena Williams I didn't realize
he's the Rhenish guy yeah Wow he's
killing it good job really dominating
life or dominating life and the last
thing is this is coming on appearance
right yes okay yeah he did well for
yourself this is Thursday morning that
means last night the first episode of
Sims and left go the show came out it's
gonna come out every Wednesday at 8 p.m.
on YouTube the BR app so definitely
check it out time out for the show I
think it's hilarious we sat down with
Tony Romo he did a Bill Belichick
impression we took Sam darn 'old on a
double-decker bus around the city it's
really the most of all the stuff that we
do that's gonna be our highest level
stuff yeah and so definitely check that
out YouTube the BR app new Sims and left
go the show for everyone that is asking
about our scheduled Sims and left go the
podcast is going to come out Tuesday
Thursday Friday mornings at 6:00 a.m.
Tuesday we'll be recapping the weekend
and also
finding where people are talking about
stuff where you're gonna be different
Sims yeah the one that comes out
Thursday is gonna be a deep dive into
your notebook and it's only gonna be the
notebook it's gonna be very raw and I'm
excited and then Friday will be our game
bets looking forward to the weekends and
then what comes out Wednesday night is
our show so you're getting us four times
your Wednesday Thursday Friday is gonna
be podcast and show yeah and then
Twitter Instagram reddit where else
those are the big ones and Facebook
Facebook YouTube yes so I can just go on
YouTube and we'll have a type The Sims
and left go show like I'm serious I'm
asking this yeah we post our podcasts on
YouTube right this show is gonna be in
the same place right okay I'll send you
a link cool
well it's in the BR app I've been
telling everybody it's in the BR app I
didn't know if I was right I was taking
a shot the dark big show today
whoa whoa big show big dock again
because I felt really bad that I did a
bunch of ass-kissing now to the back of
the Eagles fan if you're an Eagles fan
this show us for you yeah in about 10
minutes
Brian frickin Dawkins I'm gonna confess
my love over the phone through that I'm
gonna tell him that he is all my
passwords that he was my screenname I
thought I'm wearing his jersey right now
we are gonna have big Phil right in the
middle we got to get big Phil Super Bowl
prediction I would like to hear I don't
even know it I'm actually I hope he
didn't tell you and then we're gonna end
the show with a Brit from across the
pond
Jay Ajayi and running back from the
Philadelphia Eagles so yeah we got a
giant sandwich between two Eagles that's
where Phil's used to he's used to being
sandwiched between two eagle I love it I
love it
the first thing we need what are you
gonna say I was just gonna ask you're
still picking the Cowboys to go to
playoffs right right yes remind the
Eagles fans of that yes he is yeah
my dad and all of his friends we go
can't believe it I said listen I've
reached a point where I care so much
more about being right than I do about
being a homer yeah and to me I think
that's why we're different than
everybody else I can be an Eagles fan
and still pick the Cowboys because I
think that they're gonna be a better
team right and that's okay yeah and I'm
[ __ ] wrong all the time no doubt you
know what I mean yeah and this is one
that I
hope I'm actually wrong I'd love to be
proved wrong yes the one thing though
that everybody was hitting us over the
weekend I need to hear you're Khalil Mac
takes I need to hear you're Khalil Mac
takes Saturday morning where were you
when you found out I was on a bus to
Atlantic City right and my phone
exploded I were you I was actually in
South Bend Indiana and getting ready to
go into a production meeting for for
doing the game the Notre Dame Michigan
they game that night and everyone's like
you excited for the game and you're like
have you seen this I was like literally
walking to the elevator when it popped
up and I was like oh my gosh I cannot
believe this oh you get your news you
get alerts uh no I don't get alerts I
you know I'm a frequent checker of about
the same four websites over and oh so
you found out from a website not from a
text yeah no no I did not that's how I
found out I had Inklings that it was
going down and that it was serious I had
been told that on Thursday when I was
dropping out there yeah I had a source -
I was just texting football stuff with
yeah and was told like hey this cool Mac
Bears thing could be real
yeah and then two days later let's -
let's do positive and then we'll do
negative after that yeah positive Bears
holy crap holy crap we really had them
at nine and seven yeah and we said they
were right there on the fridge and I
believe you said they kind of needed
another pass rusher - yeah outside a
Leonard Floyd those 200 Quan Smith in
the middle everybody knows how we feel
about Hakeem Hicks
Eddie Goldman the defensive line does
this put them in the playoffs for you
now the thing is is if you look at both
of our brackets yeah we already had the
Packers and Vikings getting in I know
and the other teams were Falcons and
Saints right I'm not gonna change
I don't think I have the Bears in the
bud but I could we can seriously be
wrong right yeah I mean there's no doubt
Gary in general yes and the NFC North is
it is incredible because the one team
we're not talking about still has one of
the most dangerous quarterbacks on board
right and Matthew Stafford so the Bears
out like does it change the Bears that
much - I mean I know he's one of the
best players in the league it does I
think the first thing that I thought as
I went man Vic Fangio has got his
Patrick Willis and his Alden Smith from
San Francisco again he's got ro Quan to
be Patrick Willis
he's got Khalil Mak in fact I would go
damn he's got better than what he's got
San Francisco and that was a special
defense because he didn't let her Floyd
is Alden Smith ish now I know he's not
been able to be healthy a lot broken
head right so still
I think they think they're he'll be back
for a week one evil this front seven
before this trade I think we've
well-documented we would probably put it
in the top five in football already
already for Khalil now you have Khalil
Mack added to this three four scheme
with the you know whether it's the Eddie
Goldman's the Hakeem Hicks the Jonathan
Bullards you go down the line the depth
is phenomenal really is let alone the
different ways they can play it with the
versatility all we want to be small this
week we want to get to four down fronts
oh we got to play the bear front oh ok
stop by we got three huge guys to put in
the middle we put Leonard Floyd and
Khalil Mack on the edge and then you got
ro Quan Smith in the in the middle as
the middle linebacker yeah good luck
with that also right Chicago is one of
the tougher places to play they have a
great home-field advantage there with
that long grass kind of slows down every
house if the slowest field in the sport
and I'm just saying this yeah
Packers weakest part probably their
offensive line yeah it's the quiet
things right this part probably
definitely you're definitely about that
Detroit Lions yeah they've made
improvement right but we don't know how
they're gonna be exactly right if they
can neutralize the offenses the other
team yeah I think we're both confident
Nagy's ability to put points on the
board this year I am too and I think the
other thing too is a lot of people I've
had people ask me like it's just gonna
put more pressure on Mitchell too risky
to deliver no it's gonna take a lot of
pressure off them because now there's 1
of 13 14 the coach is gonna be like hey
remember we have the monsters of the
Midway about to go on the field let's
just punt it out if nothing's wide open
live to play another day they can almost
change their mindset to a degree I don't
want to say to Jackson Bill ish cuz
they're not gonna do that the ball but
they can also yes they can play a
conservative style and they're not
comfortable with the matchup of their
offense versus another defense or
they're getting a feel for a team early
on he can preach hey Matt Nagin can
preach to a true Brisky and go hey dude
like we don't have to score 21 in the
first quarter we're only 3 points down
Hollywood Jordan how are you baby give
those pass rushers a break no I'm gonna
say this to ya
Mitchell job risky
not saying is gonna have the career of
Carson Wentz I believe that Carson Wentz
is a lot better than Mitchell risky but
I see a lot of similarities I see a lot
of people saying that Mitchell trip
Brisky was was not good at all less yeah
I'm so sick of that his number one
receiver
I don't even think is on a team right
now last year no I don't think he is
either hold on I'm gonna look it up I'm
not even sure their number one receiver
well my line that I always go to more
than anything is you know what I say I'm
always like their best receiver on their
team last year was Kendall right what
was yes Kendall right but really not
only Kendall writes on a team right no I
don't think it was Tariq Cohen was their
best receiver so then physically he was
their second receiver right but I look
at the team I think the offensive line
has gotten better
I think the weapons have gotten better I
think the offensive coach has gotten
better
I think the tight end has gotten a ton
better yeah so you still have Adam XI
now you had Trey Burton right I think
that Mitchell true Biscay played well
last year they were in every game down
the stretch and I have a lot of
confidence that he's gonna continue to
improve I do too I again I'm not a stat
guy you know that it's about the look
and what's realistically there to be had
and what you can realistically expect
from the guy in that position that had
to play it yeah they were banged up on
the offensive line I'm talking myself
into them going ten wins well I mean
they're up there they're they're that
kind of team I mean I don't think you're
talking and everything it's they're
gonna be they're gonna be it's just
gonna be a difference of did they stop
Rogers on the last Drive of the game
it's gonna be some of those types of
situations first game of the year
he is very agent Kendall right to you he
was her number one receiver right now
bears-packers first game of the year do
you know how important that games gonna
be yes we both had the Vikings winning
the division and the Packers taken the
wild card Bears and Packers those two
games could define who makes the wild
card out of the NFC North they really
could and the thing about getting a pass
rusher is when Rodgers has time he can
tear up that bear secondary that is the
weakness of that defense right now no
doubt but I don't know if it's that way
it's not that way I'm just saying
compared everything else either the
weakness right
but if you can get after Rodgers you can
nullify the need for those corners to
hold us as long as they have right
agreed the worst game I've ever seen
Aaron Rodgers play in my life is by far
Denver Broncos the year the Broncos won
the Super Bowl in Denver if you remember
it was right before the Green Bay
Packers bye week and I'm gonna pull it
up real quick just so we have it so I
can speak specifically to hit but keep
going I can find it if you yeah it's
alright I'm on it that was a 2015 season
I'm gonna have it here in two seconds
here we are
they lost twenty nine to ten but the
point is what you're saying that that
defense is on Miller Vaughn Hiller
DeMarcus Ware Jags right they were able
to go oh okay yeah you want Aaron
Rodgers wants to dance around all day
that's what he wants we got cover guys
and we're just gonna send four freaks at
you yes and good luck trying to buy time
on that all day and that was Aaron
Rodgers worst game he was 14 for 22 for
77 yards total right well I've never
even heard a stat line they lost
I know it's cuz it's the only time and
they lost 29 to 10 they were totally
dominate that was the start of me going
this is not Aaron Rodgers this is Denver
this is well and this is their offense
remember that was about the time where I
said their offense sucks it's the same
five plays all game and you just can't
expect to be the defense like Denver in
that type of environment
but yeah I think you're gonna have
something similar maybe not to quite the
corner play
yeah but fuller those safeties and
you're right the other guys that we need
to see in Chicago are the Nickelback the
other corners because they're the ones
didn't be attacked we are gonna do the
other side of this the Oakland Raiders
the Las Vegas Raiders the questions of
Gruden in a second Brian Dawkins I can't
believe I'm saying his name is about to
call in which is awesome Josh just kind
of give me the heads-up
did you crossed over with Dawkins for a
year 2000 and let's see 9 we were in
Denver together you think he's gonna
remember you of course he is I stood
with it I stood next to him a little bit
in pregame warmups the Super Bowl this
year you know cuz he works for the
Eagles so Joe and I was on the field
there and you know I always I like out
of all the guys I played with I mean
he's like one of the godfathers I played
but that's what I would say he is that's
interesting yeah the Eagles refer to
Jason Peters as a godfather I don't know
right he's like when he says something
everybody shuts that's right and that's
what Brian Dawkins was like if he came
in the in the locker room it was like
here that I go mr. Dawkins here's the
entrance to the locker room
like I was gonna get out of his way he
had earned that respect not only from
what I had seen just in my years in the
league but from what I saw I'm doing a
daily preparation and how awesome of a
guy and a man he was we're gonna do this
then after he gets off I'd like to know
other famous Godfather's in the NF okay
that sounds pretty cool yeah I played it
with a few of them oh yes I don't I want
people to understand my love for this
person I think they're gonna understand
thank you and now the greatest safety to
have ever played a Hall of Famer my
screen name growing up and 95% of my
passwords it is the Godfather
Brian Wolverine Dawkins P doc how are
you hey are you doing what's up man - it
is God that was awesome you totally got
me I was like damn something's wrong
with b-dawg voice we're amazing I'm just
gonna start off with a story I'm gonna
embarrass myself
go ahead Brian I tell this story all the
time too many times Ryan I'm sick of
hearing it I I am the biggest Brian
Dawkins fan ever
I cried multiple times during your
speech and it was beautiful I don't know
if you remember I think it was your
nephew daelin played at Trinity High
School in Kentucky and you went to one
of his games do you remember a camera
man running at you and hugging you and
asking you did you really want to go to
Denver and leave Philadelphia do you
remember that moment I wish I could say
I did yes wow that was a better answer I
like that you didn't remember this this
it was on sequential person it was only
like the biggest moan of my life thank
you very much I'm wearing Jersey right
now he is he's well he's wearing a
Jersey being I remember a very
enthusiastic cameraman I do
thank you okay all right good recovery
good recovery he called inaudible he
checked to the safety blitz there Thanks
in all serious now serious
I don't know why was trying to say there
your Hall of Fame speech was it
completely improvised um pretty much you
know I've for a while now just write
down a word or a name or something and
then I let it filter through my heart so
whatever comes out at that time is what
I feel like that at that moment for that
individual or or for that subject matter
and so I wanted to do that at the speech
and you know that's what I do here the
Lord put those things in my heart I
thank those individuals and and to bear
a little bit about you know who I am and
where I've been was for different people
in the audience and for those who watch
it on TV it was beautiful and I feel
like you showed everybody up by putting
the gold jacket around your wife I feel
like everyone else's wife was like I
could have used a gold jacket you know
what I had I heard that I heard that
some of the one of the other Hall of
Famers was went up and I think that I
was something that was said I don't
think pretty kindly by some of the other
wives up there yeah in the booth up once
they went up at the after the event B
dock I mean first of all Congrats on the
Hall of Fame and and all that I mean III
was calling you the Godfather before you
came on here because I said you were one
of those type of guys in the locker room
when we were together in Denver in 2009
first of all the speech was the one of
the best speeches I have ever seen and
you out Ray Lewis to Ray Lewis I just
hope you know that okay which is not
easy to do but you were way cooler than
Ray Lewis too in all facets so I want to
say congrats on that because that truly
was a special speech but go ahead you
want to say something go ahead it was it
was and you know there was some things
that that was all me to what is here and
I really wanted to share it and I really
at the same time I wanted to be
respectful of my my classmates time so
that's our Russian just a little bit
over some of the things that I said but
I wanted to get as many as many things
out of my heart as I could
yeah you did a good job and this is this
is one thing I've always wondered about
you and and hopefully you can answer
this I mean we are in the era where you
were certainly you're one of the
greatest safeties never deployed
game the last 15 to 20 years I feel like
two safeties other than in Philadelphia
have been mainstream names not that you
weren't and I don't mean that you were
cheated in any ways but I feel like when
people always talk it said Reid and Troy
Polamalu and that conversation did you
ever like through time go like hey damn
I'm as good as those guys maybe even
better in some areas did you ever feel
cheated that you weren't part of that
conversation more okay the thing about
me is you know always try to let my play
speak for myself and any accolades that
then come my way they come my way if
they don't they don't I mean you know
the main reason that I played the game
the way that I played it was not just
for myself as for my teammates it was I
was blessed to be able to do it and I
love the heck out of it and so you know
when I'm not if I'm not mentioning and
in a in a conversation with other people
and that's that's their opinions at
those times I think that you know if you
look at the way that I played the game
um there was not a weak area in my game
know and that's the one that's the one
thing I wanted to make sure that
happened I wanted there to be no weak
area in my game I wanted every
opportunity for me to affect the game to
be filled up with stats like you look at
my look at the way that I played the
game that's that's the way that I went
about doing it I think those guys did a
are excellent and what they did and I
was getting the ball and intercepting
the ball and returning for touchdown
that was not my skill set like it's
force return yards that was not me but
getting but getting the ball getting
turnovers in multiple ways that was me
and so if you were someone who you think
the only way that you can affect the
ball game a free safety position is by
getting interceptions then you would
you're gonna love the heck out of those
guys cuz you're supposed to but if
you're someone that understands the
magnitude of a guy that can do multiple
things and affect the ball games in them
in a variety of different ways across
the board then you would appreciate it
the way that I play the game mmm
I love it I'm loving this and we're
getting Brian Dawkins because of horizon
you got to check out Verizon up the
company's loyalty program you can redeem
tickets for hundreds of NFL experiences
throughout the years this week alone the
reason we're getting Brian Dawkins him
and Brent Celek
they're getting meet
greets with Philadelphia fans you get a
once-in-a-lifetime experience to play
flag football with Randall Cunningham
cracks off so enroll in Verizon up
appreciate that shout to my girl Audrey
that's kind of making this all happen
I'm a Verizon guy I refuse to do
anything else with myself a cellular
phone
Brian I've always wondered this when you
hit algae Crumpler did you feel his soul
leave his body I mean you hit a grunt I
mean when you get somebody like that
it's just like you get cut to the
stomach you know there's a huge grunt
that you hear air exhaling and I'm you
know for me I'm I'm surprised that he
was able to get up and finish the game
so that tells you about what type of uh
you know will that dude had but you know
that don't hurt me too
that's one thing that people don't have
to understand is that that job hurt me
and I knew it was gonna hurt crying he's
a big dude hi I I play flag football
like algae Crumpler I have a same
midsection and lower body but bright you
know what including that one algae
Crumpler Mike Vick when he got the
touchdown but you destroyed him and the
Ike Hilliard hit of those three which
one was the one that you thought was the
biggest impact the biggest hit where you
like walked away from him whoa that was
that was a collision it would be the one
michael vick cuz i was running full
speed and he was running full speed
pretty much and you know that was that
was one that knocked me out so like that
it will be that one yes that would take
the cake that was awesome be be done
I've tried that his speech after the NFC
Championship game give me some respect
it's total feeling game oh yes oh that's
where I want to go with this I mean
because I've tried to explain to fan boy
over here that about you playing with
you in the 2009 season in Denver you had
the greatest gameday transformation I
was ever a part of in my career but you
know it's Monday through Saturday you're
quiet you're humble and I remember the
first time I walked into the locker room
on a Sunday
when we were in Denver together and you
were you know doing cartwheels in their
locker room and in tents and yelling and
going crazy already I just want to know
how did you wake up that morning and
kind of put yourself into that frame in
life are you talking to yourself in the
car ride over there how did that how
does it all come to that point well it
was a crescendo effect throughout the
week of the game film of practicing the
way that I practice you notice how I
practiced our price as fast as I could
in practice I practiced like it was game
time so but the game would be slower for
me so you know all during the week
building up building up and so the more
I understand about the opposing team the
more I'm going to be able to hopefully
exploit some things that they don't
probably know they're not doing or
something that I just can do today this
don't understand so I'm getting more and
more amped and more excited and so that
morning you know it's just again I'm
still trying to be calm because what I'm
trying to do is I'm trying to save as
much and at least as much energy at the
right time I don't want to play the game
too fast you've heard that many times
but many people don't want to play the
game confess the other thing is I played
the game at least four times in my mind
already by that time and so I'm just
anxious to get on the field I'm anxious
to get going so I'm listening to slow
music as much as I can not getting too
height and then once it gets close and
you saw me in the in the locker room
once it gets close to going out for
warm-ups I can't contain it no more I
try to contain as long as I can so now I
have to start doing some yelling the
reason I yell so much so I had to let
some of that junk out right like that's
what that's real I was yelling so much
that's what I came off as III believe it
yeah and so that's and once you I want
someone to feel once I go off a warm
loss you know it's go time
so I'm in full effect I'm a full effect
alright it was amazing man I'm just
gonna tell you from I gift guy that
played football but like truly I'm a fan
because I grew up in it playing with you
that year was truly like it was awesome
to see and awesome to see what you did
on a Sunday that made you so special so
I just want to let you know that yeah
well you know I think the other thing
you did is you caught me at a in a year
then one team basically said I was not
able to do what I used to do
and I was going to a team that said you
know what we still believe that you can
do it and so I was I was I was man have
no idea if I was gonna show hey I was
gonna show the Eagles that they made a
mistake right
I let me go and I was gonna show the
Broncos that you made the right decision
about bringing me not this is a player
but as a person to lead these young men
and hopefully help change the culture
around there yeah they did make a
mistake Brian before you go again shout
out to Verizon and Verizon up for making
this possible I may have made a mistake
I care about my job I'm a fan but I want
to be right and we were picking division
winners before the year and I picked the
Cowboys to win the East if you could get
a little upset at me and tell me why
like that I'm wrong in like an angry
Brian Dawkins voice I'd appreciate it no
I just don't understand the rationale
behind it like this set aside at that
that is the Cowboys but it's the fact
that you look at the team that I think
is gonna be the toughest time you desire
to be honest with you but they just
picked up a young men in a draft yeah
that's gonna give them the ability to
run a football yeah and then you already
have a you know a tidy and then they
draft last year that's probably gonna be
a Pro Bowler your soul and then they
have one of the best receivers in the
game you know on the outside so all that
being said to meet after teams that
people need to work out look out for
good whether you're wrong left go all
right I know we have to let you go
I just want to ask this last thing and
you can make it quick out of all the
guys you played against and had the
tackle kind of going back to that who
was the one guy you were like damn this
big suckers coming at me right now is
there anybody that was that guy to you I
mean I you played in the era of Edgerrin
James and Curtis Martin and Ricky
Williams was there anybody that stands
out to you that way are you just
Wolverine and you destroy whatever you
say no there's nobody that that brought
that type of response out of me to do
that I follow respected the most of how
hard II ran was Marshawn Lynch Wow he
gives to do did you respect it the most
because you knew there's gonna be a
flat-out war every time you tackle he's
not gonna go down the first hit he's not
gonna go down with the second pull the
tug he's gonna continue to fight for
every answer so you knew you had to have
sometimes you knew you telling cast to
make sure you
to the ball that we're right you know
you're not gonna be a thing to do
knocked down by yourself on a consistent
basis right but yeah let me make make
sure we finish up on this like you know
and the reason why I'm here you said it
was for our Verizon but it's not just
all those things you mentioned I think
that they're also allowing people to
create memories and you know I just
finished with a meet and greet with
people coming in and being able to take
pictures and they put up a nice replica
of you know the pole Green's pool that
they put up and after the oh that's the
ball yeah so they put up something
forgot for tips for plans to come in and
take pictures with me and you mentioned
breath and you mentioned a Randle so I
think they're doing a good job of
letting people create memories and I
think that's a powerful thing for people
to have you've given me a lifetime of
them Brian thank you so much man one day
we will meet and we will shake hands and
it will be beautiful
until then probably I'm gonna jump on
your back coming from me Dawkins you the
man did you do man be good be doc he's
the man I know you alright you blushing
over there awesome question with you
asking about how he kind of gets ready
thanks the fact that he goes through the
game four times in his mind that's I
never heard him say that that's
fascinating and the fact that he would
be so quiet all day because as a fan all
I would see would be the tunnel or there
was the one pregame video that I feel
like it's always online of him being
like right he like throws his elbows
back and kicks his knee up so you didn't
know that either I didn't know I
expected to see a guy that was like that
all week usually when guys are psycho
there's a psycho psycho yes like they
don't have the ability to cut it off and
be this like humble you know you know
Christian man like he is and be that
kind of way where yes I mean during the
week he practiced hard but it was never
yelling at anybody no it was always
doesn't curse no anybody who talked to
somebody somebody did wrong you know I
hate you need to watch this I mean it
was literally at that kind of talk oh my
god so he was really saving his energy I
if you think about his Hall of Fame
speech he talked about how all the best
things happen after a bad thing happens
and it's about using that energy and
saving it to explode at the right
moments I'm a huge believer in energies
I think a lot of people are out there
and if you think about it when you yell
right afterwards you're very calm right
he saved that energy for those moments I
am still a fan I'll be a fan until I'm
old and great he's the kind of guy you
should always be a fan of because he's
not an awesome role model awesome player
everything and great did you enjoy it
yeah what was your takes from back
that's watching you barely able to
contain yourself and just have to put
your head in your lap and smile for 15
minutes I was literally like I'm gonna
take my mouth away from the microphone
or else I'm just gonna be like and then
there was that one time that like you
were incredible at one time at band camp
you had that game against the Texans and
then there was that other time but yes
or the Michael Vick hit remember that
how I remember that Michael Vick just
like they diving in the end zone right
basically he kind of ran and like the
right side of his body exploded and they
were both laying in the end zone for
like 20 seconds I remember just kind of
like both healing yes yeah they the
Eagles had the Falcons number the only
other questions I would've wanted to ask
him is just to talk about Jim Johnson
and how much he meant to him just
because I feel like there was like a
father-son relationship I just want to
hear the greatest hits I just want to
know yeah I get it the Jim Johnson he
was special and he was a guy that knew
how to use Brian Dawkins yes I mean I
prepared for things in week one of my
first game and my career when we when I
was asked we went to Lane right and Joe
Gervais just at exactly right but I can
still remember Gruden being so stressed
out not only about be doc and the talent
of your team but that these Jim Jonsin
blitzes and they were listeners from
everywhere and they were not they
brought blitz is that truly I'm not
gonna lie to you that I saw there and
week one that I never saw anybody do the
rest of my career he sometimes they were
unethical you'd be like that's not sound
like he did bring a linebacker and a
safety on the same side but also bring
the end like not leave anyone bad week
that's what we would call that usually
it'd be like four week would be that's
he would bring five week and he would
use like an outside linebacker like
quinton cave or something just to take
up a block and go doc we'll get there
right he'll get there in time yeah or
he'd bring a corner back blitz an ax
linebacker but Gruden would get off I
mean get off like if he found one oh you
know or if he if we blocked that blitz
it was a gain of one but we blocked on
that he literally it was like that don't
cut that out Josh let's talk about the
other side yeah we didn't go there right
Oakland Oakland here's a list of things
that Jon Gruden has done so first
question yes is Jon Gruden the acting GM
for the Oakland Raiders in your mind yes
yeah I think so I do when they traded
from 10 to 15 to select kolten Miller
they did not great get get great
compensation at all right actually
that's when they went from 15 to 10 yeah
right this is your spot they traded a
third-round pick four martavis Bryant
they cut him right they traded a
fifth-round pick for AJ McCarron they
probably didn't have to trade anything
agreed then in the Bears trade for
Khalil but he had to assure he gets him
so I understand but I've been a seven
because he because yet probably cuz he
was just scared to death that he's not
gonna have a backup for his team in the
trade for the two first round picks they
gave a second and fifth for a third and
a sixth like they like they took away
some of the value from the two
first-round pick yes it seems to be
willy-nilly right now first he says that
he wants Khalil Mak then it comes out he
didn't need Khalil Mak it really sounded
like it was all an ego where he was like
oh you don't want to come in here well
then you can get the hell out of here
I want to know my big question and I
don't know the answer of this but the
first thing is did was this always in
the plan because what what I never going
to pay when I when I connect the dots
and you go damn well they done after
they drafted Colt Miller they drafted
three defensive linemen after that now
they needed help on the D line or didn't
key right PJ Hall and her oh yeah so I
go okay was this always in the like like
he doesn't agree to a deal that's really
like Mario Edwards yes so those are the
things that I thought of it first
I've heard a few things and I'm gonna
try to do my best to kinda hear through
the back channels of football but uh
yeah
I don't know what happened there with
Gruden and Khalil Mack there was
obviously very little communication
that's what I know for sure it sounded
like was offended by the first offer
that I think he ended overall that's
what I'm starting to hear from some of
my NFL friends okay is that he was
offended overall by the way your phone
oh it's my watch yeah that's gonna be I
gotta turn that thing off
that thing's - just get that one good
technology was a birthday president nice
yep so that was where my first first my
brain went first the other thing is you
know and then I went to dam Gruden's you
know kind of accumulating all these old
players again right the oldest player on
the team all the sleep team in the
league yeah always feeling by far right
and I mean again I'm not concerned I
understand the way Gruden is right
burden in a really bad off she doesn't
trust young guys and that's always to me
been a little bit of a flaw when did you
realize that about him I'm gonna say my
second day trying to get him help
like it wasn't long because he would let
you know I mean so I don't trust young
guys I mean young guys mess up they mess
up this protection or this scheme on
coverage whatever he wants his guys to
do what the coaches tell them and I get
that that's crazy because they traded a
made man for two future young guys I
know I guess it kind of goes against
what your suit does go against what I'm
saying I'm saying for his overall team
building I feel like damn he's 96 he's
not 22 uh the other thing I you know oh
okay yeah you know again to go to the I
want to say this part just to go to the
Bears real quick with how much money
they paid like and I know we texted this
back and forth but people also have to
remember that they don't have to pay two
first-round picks so that's like minus
48 million dollars flying on it I'm
gonna get it 0% chance yes that the but
that the Raiders with those two first
round picks yeah get anybody that is as
good as Khalil Mac I'm willing to I know
we're not gonna find this out for 3-4
years we will remember do you know how
hard it is to find a Khalil Mac do you
know how hard it is I know
and also how's Reggie McKenzie feeling
well he found the diamond in the rough
from Buffalo took him at five and then
got car in the second round the future
offensive and defensive players and you
gave one of them away
Derek Carr feelin let me read a quote
from when Derek Carr signed his contract
he said the main thing I could just
remember during negotiations was all
along the way I was like how do we keep
my teammates is this new deal good for
Gabe Jackson is it good for Khalil Mack
is it good for a Maury Cooper Derek Carr
got paid but he took less to make sure
that Khalil Mack one of his best friends
on the team was still there could Gruden
have lost the team already is it
possible I don't know he's a quarterback
is going I did this for the team and you
[ __ ] me I don't think he's gonna lose
a team but they're definitely gonna be
questioning him as a player I would be
in the locker room going wait wait wait
hold on let me hear this our best player
who's an extremely hard worker who was
an NFL defensive MVP who really is the
only upper echelon player on the
defensive side of the ball that we have
he was a top five pick by our
organization and he's done everything
right on the field like inexcusable and
we don't reward him that that's gonna
what's gonna make players go wait so who
gets rewarded around here that just a
quarterback that that's the issue that I
think will fall in line there so that's
scary we talked about the older team
which I want to say to some but to that
point you know it's a lot of lot of
pressure to be putting that you know
what I told you yesterday on the coaches
that's what you're doing when you get an
older team you're going my game plan is
so good on the offense and defensive
side of the ball that as long as they
just do what we coach them we're gonna
win the game and I'm just sorry that's
not the way it's gonna go down
I wonder there's only been one guy I've
seen that can do that Belichick exactly
I'm I want our podcast to be useful and
I'm a Raiders fan I'm upset right now
yeah for Raiders problem for the Raiders
- so let's be productive yeah I'm gonna
be sad Raiders fan yeah you make me feel
better right okay yeah Chris we just
signed this coach /gm to a 10-year 100
million dollar contract it's impossible
to move on from this guy he's assuring
us into Las Vegas
and he just traded away our best asset
after having an off season of
questionable moves what can I do to feel
better can you please help me because
right now I'm really sad about my
football team I think the thing is you
gotta I would say that hey Jon Gruden
has built this team before and made it
special in the early 2000s he wasn't
that Tony Dunne geez roster writer sir
he did go to Tampa and yes the team was
not his roster but he did get them over
the hump the hump that they weren't able
to get with Tony Dungy there so he gave
them enough well he knows what it takes
to win a Super Bowl or build a team that
is a Superbowl caliber team hey let's
not forget I mean the Raiders they could
have won the Super Bowl the year the
Patriots did if it weren't for the Tuck
rule and that was Jon Gruden coaching
that team and of course I think we all
think they got ripped off by the Tuck
rule to a degree so I would say that and
if I was really trying to defend this I
don't believe this so I only want to
hear the things you believe okay I think
we're not where these podcasts is gonna
be like okay I thought you were just
trying to tell me to defend you in
general I want I want truth right that's
positive yeah okay they only know the
truth I could give you that's that's
truly positive is hey one guy does not
make your defense and even if it's a
defensive MVP no it doesn't make your
defense because I would say that hey
listen we could still look at last year
and go this was the what was it last
year the 23rd best defense in football
with our defense MVP so you can say okay
yeah I didn't make our defense that much
better but I don't believe that I think
that's a bunch of bullcrap I can't even
really say that damn I know I can't say
that he's the best player on their team
hands down and now what he's doing is
going okay so my offense and Derek Carr
we are gonna probably have to score 30
points and we're gonna have to see the
car clutch factor come all back into
play like we saw two years ago it was
unbelievably intense that year was 25th
and football but this is the thing I
think people miss off and this is the
where Jon Gruden misses these points and
I'll even say maybe Bill Belichick but
Belichick gets away with it because he's
like The Wizard of [ __ ] eyes okay and
no other coaches him so I'm not gonna
compare anybody to him but going back to
what we talked about when you have a
veteran team as long as they do what I
say as long as they do what I say and do
our game plan we're gonna win okay
that's tremendous pressure on your
coaching staff and you're not gonna win
that way all the time you're not at some
point or another players have to make
some plays for you to get some of those
wins okay and that's where Coolio Mack
was clutch okay whether it was the year
that they were going into the playoffs
that Derek Carr got hurt
how many big-time fourth-quarter sack
sack exact pick six yes you know what I
mean all those type of plays they can't
be quantified because of the big player
in the big moment did I use that
correctly yeah it's just unbelievable
that he makes an entire good point and
then turns into a five-year-old because
he said quantify because I was going to
my brain and then because you're here
you just can't I can't help it can I ask
that question we got an email yesterday
from the Bears rent so we got an email
from gyro aka llama the Bears fan this
is how he refers to himself he said
following the trade I've heard many
people compare Mac to LT and I feel like
the comparison is kind of ridiculous my
question is on a scale of one to ten how
ridiculous is that comparison are they
actually comparable I know Mac is
amazing but I never watched LT in person
so I'd love to hear Sims thoughts on it
they are comparable so it's not
ridiculous it's not ridiculous no it's
not ridiculous I think the reason he
says it's ridiculous when I think of
Lawrence Taylor I think of a speed demon
off the edge right when I think of
Khalil Mac I think of a large man that
pushes people in right the quarter I
know but they're the measurably wise
they're almost the same like they're
both like 6-3 to 55 to 59 somewhere in
that range so Mac was like a - I don't
know but he's just he's built different
like he's in high cut waist with
unbelievable legs and ass and then he's
just neck in arms after that I'm not
gonna he's not as talented the pass
rusher and speed pass rusher like you're
saying Lawrence Taylor is better along
those lines
the reason Lawrence Taylor is always
gonna be held in such high prestige is
because he's the first Khalil Mac in the
league he's the first of his kind we had
never seen a guy that went whoa wait
he's 255 and he's faster than our
running backs that was unheard of he's
faster than most of our receivers except
our best receiver so that's why it's
crazy
that's why the Lawrence Taylor lore is
so huge kula Mac is not quite the
talented pass rusher but Coolio Mac is
better versed to run I think that's
another phase of the game that doesn't
get talked about with Cleo Mac yeah :
Mac is one of the best run stopping
defensive ends in football you cannot
block him with tight ends he throws them
around like they're children so that's
another facet he brings to the football
game and I think he's gonna be able to
used in a lot different ways with the
Bears because of Fangio and the three
four four three hybrid type scheme they
were they use all right sorry Raiders I
know so I feel bad for you ready it
ain't over though let's just see let's
see what happens some other people I
feel bad for I feel bad for Jerick
McKinnon and others fans him going on
the IR I know that Kyle had a lot of
high hopes for him yeah do you have high
hopes for Alfred Morris and Matt Breda
filling in I do
I would then my first worry is if one
gets hurt it's like oh crap okay I mean
I think their only guy on the other guy
in the roster is motes er right is that
the only other thing back in most three
running backs
none of them are Jerick McKinnon I mean
Jerick McKinnon is he was special in the
fact that he was awesome in the past
game but he also had some of these
strong power elements of a between the
tackles runner not that he was like
Ezekiel Elliott sledge hammer but
certainly could run through tackles and
get you tough yards when you wanted so
you you had a basically plan for two
different type of offenses when he's on
the field yes
now when Alfred Morris is in you're just
gonna go huh probably gonna be a run I
know guys are in it's gonna be now
something else might happen I feel like
the most valuable guys gonna be use
check use check look I kind of feel like
he's I used more in that running back
role now
he is definitely gonna always be the
trick um and dickham guy okay that's
that's what he's waiting on the wheel
and right and put him up on a line he's
a fullback who's you know it looks like
the runs going right but he snuck behind
the offensive line to come out the other
side and Kyle throws one was patented
bootlegs you were talking about Bill
Belichick being a wizard yeah the
Patriots only kept three wide receivers
on their roster which is really
incredible when you think about it yeah
Julian Edelman suspended it's going to
be Hogan Dorsett and corner old
Patterson as the three wide receivers on
the team but
you factor in the fact that they have
Dwayne Allen and Rob Gronkowski tight
end and I think they're expecting
Hollister to be there as well you factor
in James white Rex Burkhead as good pass
catching running backs they're freeing
up so many roster spots elsewhere by
only keeping three it's just you know
balichek's trying something new
Belichick is trying something and he
knows that they have the right personnel
they they always have a failsafe plan so
that's why they have that Sonia Michele
will eventually come exactly right and
like you said with the running backs and
all that and their ability to contribute
in the pass game and then you know hey
the two tight ends I know it hasn't been
great for Dwayne Dwayne Allen but he's
still gonna be able to contribute to
that to a degree so they're gonna find
different ways yeah life with Julian
Edelman is not gonna be their favorite
thing in the world but guys like Chris
Hogan and Phillip Dorsett can do a dual
role of filling that role like that
they're capable of doing those inner in
you know underneath option route jerk
routes all those things so they'll use
them accordingly and they'll trust even
like the Rexburg heads of the world and
is up to do that as well totally see
James white and Rex Burkhead be inflects
outs no doubt about it
and much Tony Michels capable of that
too want to hear something you were
right about yes i rave in his wave to
Prashad Perryman wanna hear something
else you were right about Terrell Davis
got a phone call from a certain Broncos
running back asking him to wear the
number 30 and his response was
permission granted he's an outstanding
young man and it was time to dust off
the old three oh that man's name Phillip
Lindsey Phillip Lindsey is your guy this
young running back for the Broncos will
be rocking the Tyrell Davis third as you
know that that's unbelievable that's
that's big-time I can't believe first
light I can't I didn't know
hall-of-famer numbers could be given out
if the hall-of-famer player says yes you
could do it so Lindsey called him up
Lindsey called them up which just takes
some huge Kahuna's on his part but he is
a Colorado kid I don't know if he grew
up in Colorado but I know he went to
Colorado so he obviously has an
appreciation for them and cool for tour
TD is like a Brian Dawkins one of the
best stand-up humans I've ever been
around
I'll also say this we've now interviewed
Terrell Davis together like three times
yeah I feel like I wish we could have
the unfiltered T
before the mic comes on and I feel like
if we got him in our new podcast room
where he doesn't realize the cameras up
man you could get him in right because
whole sit down and I'm like dude I just
want to drink with you and chill yeah
and then he gets on camera and he's a
little bit more professional
no down I could totally hang out with
Terrell Davis I could do I watched Hard
Knocks last night oh I didn't watch it
um have you ever been waved I have what
is so I'm Way too you know Broncos the
van the Bucs in the box so I'm in the
Titans I'm watching these guys to get
called in by Elliott wolf the assistant
GM and they go through the process what
is that was it during roster cut downs
two of them were and then one was off
season so Denver the year I had was in
2009 with him
it was the offseason I had been it was
about time to come back and I had only
got a little inkling of a chance to play
in Denver my year my year I got to play
in a game against the San Diego Chargers
at the time where I started but knew
Kyle Orton was gonna be put in the game
if things didn't go smoothly he was
healthy and he had played the first I
don't know twelve weeks of the year and
it was a tough situation for me I'm
gonna defend myself to degree I didn't
play well and it could have done better
certainly but I also I would like to
recognize and I'm gonna wreck make sure
you recognize is that during that during
that preseason and stuff I was
phenomenal I really did I played great I
got hurt in preseason game three against
the Seattle Seahawks hurt my ankle but
to the point where that was the year if
you remember Kyle word and trait we
traded the Jay Cutler thing and you look
like six now or six and all and they had
to make Kyle Orton work right they
traded Jay Cutler for him so they had to
make it work and I don't think I'm
speaking out of line here that I
outperformed Kyle Ward in practice
almost on a daily basis and in the first
preseason game and a half I certainly
did to the point where they stopped
giving me reps and Josh acknowledged it
he's like I'm actually really
comfortable with you but I gotta kind of
build this other guy up right now and I
said Josh I get it I've been around the
NFL I understand do your thing but then
I really got no reps towards the end of
priests
reason and then we going into the season
you always heard that story a million
times where you don't get reps a lot as
a backup quarterback other than some
scout team crap so then it comes okay
it's time to play it I had a great week
of practice and everybody was like dude
you're about to Wally PIPP or you're
about to Wally PIPP Borden and I got to
the game that day and I could still
remember and I was just like I walked
into the locker room and I remember
there again Orton can go we're gonna
start you but he can go and I was like
the worst knows news I could hear cuz
you're pumped up all more I just we
talked about the Brian Dawkins right
ready all morning like you're like it's
starting time right and then the first
thing you hear is you might not go right
so I'm already going Tim am I gonna
start and oh no you're gonna start oh
great thanks thanks to that vote of
confidence that's great and you know
like we said we didn't get any points
the first two drives I had a back mess
up on a free safety week linebacker
blitz he didn't cross over the formation
to pick the guy up I got sacked a next
series I got hit from behind and fumbled
on like a third down when we were in
like field goal range and then they took
me out and that was that what was my
point of this three you can talk about
you getting waived so the next year
sorry this is a long story
the next year now we're going to the
offseason I'm on vacation now I'm coming
back from OTAs and like the day before
we're gonna start off season training
they signed Brady Quinn and I'm going
damn I mean hopefully that's not for me
right whatever I'm kind of just trying
to block it out whatever I walk in the
facility that day and I'm there maybe
about an hour an hour and a half man and
I saw the cut guy coming towards me the
cut guy you always know you always know
who the cut guy is it's like this one
guy that's kind of underling upstairs in
the front office that they send down to
beat you can you come upstairs we need
to talk so how do you cuz my thought
about Chris Simms yeah this is how I
would picture right you see the guy
coming and you go son of all right I
know I'm cut I'm coming I said I kind of
said something like oh gosh you damn I
just but I was really upset and
heartbroken and like I think I cried
I've cried in front of Josh a little bit
like yeah just cuz I was you know I'm
just upset she died thanks sorry I love
football
yeah so yes him Brian Sanders and they
were great with me and said all the
things but yeah that's never easy is
there anything a coach can say that it
actually makes it feel better
ah is it just kind of say listen man
like we really appreciate what you did
they were like yeah they said appreciate
it we respect you you were great in the
locker room and and Josh trying to gave
me something like hey if something
happens here I'm not afraid to call you
back that was what I kind of had someone
okay he might have been lying to me or
whatever it made me feel somewhat better
did you mind if I pick up another scab
come on bucks yeah what was that way of
like cuz that's your first wave that was
my first wave I knew it was coming at
least because I had had my spleen injury
yeah and then I the next year I couldn't
play at all so I'm now I'm at a football
for a year and a half and I knew there
was a good chance I wanted them to just
release me they kept holding on to me
hoping people would trade for me right I
was telling everybody don't trade for me
you knew you were messed up I knew I was
messed up I knew I was gonna be helping
out so I was trying to tell anybody that
I knew big Mortensen's at practice Adam
Schefter is at practice you're like hey
guys I'm not healthy don't I just tell
it's not the cheese right I literally
was saying that you're like the only
player in the NFL trying not to get
right exactly right and so that day came
and Mark Dominic who's been on ESPN and
all that got who's awesome dude I mean I
love mark down who's the GM of the Bucks
so he wasn't a GM he was the assistant
GM Bruce Allen was the GM but he called
that day like on cut day and I mean I
thought I was getting kind of wasn't
sure but he's like hey you're still in
the roster right now he's like we're we
got some teams calling so we don't know
what's gonna happen but just bear with
us or whatever but I think yeah cool
whatever whatever so then a few hours go
by nothing happens and he they call me
in and the thing I always take away from
that day is that I didn't Jon Gruden
didn't never said anything to me
but he's also famous for that's what he
does so it's not that it was personal
but Jon Gruden doesn't talk to the
players after their cut which I don't
agree with wouldn't you say that most
coaches do all OH
I mean I don't know he's the only one I
know I just say something to every
player that gets cut just about every
time I watch hard knock they bring them
in to say bye to the coach the coach
David sit down a few Jackson and he
would go listen man I love you like a
kid I appreciate you a lot
we just couldn't have it keep working
hard it just
something like that exactly Jeff Fischer
did it last year yeah and it's it's like
40 seconds but it's sort of that face to
face right so what a man does that's
just what a man does and I'm not trying
to say John gern's done a man don't get
me wrong this is not what he has done I
don't want to be but but it did bother
me because I also was like damn I mean
we had a lot of years together we had
some good moments together we were in a
[ __ ] quarterback room with each other
like all the [ __ ] time we were in the
though you know holders together you
know we're just talking about as a human
as a human wouldn't you want to say
goodbye exactly right so and and you've
heard from other people that's he does
that all the time no that's what he does
that's what he does yeah have you asked
him about that now
so you left and did that kind of stew in
you a little bit yeah I was doing me
that's messed up I remember walking up
there and like his his door was closed
and they were saying he was out already
of the building I don't know if he was
or not I didn't but I didn't believe
anything at that point but yeah I wish
she opens it up and be like oh that was
that was let's see
he had already moved my picture outside
of his door so you get home and did you
go Danielle yeah for that kind of thing
I just went home she knew already cuz I
was like they would call me at home and
that's we don't go there right so she
knew she knew it was coming but then it
was it that was a world whatever time
then I went to the that was week one Tom
Brady hurt his knee oh the hit from the
safe room and you know Baltimore Ravens
safety he was also on the Chiefs yeah he
did the split on Harden and he hurt
Gronkowski in the AFC Championship game
the year our listeners are going Dollard
Pollard Bernard Pollard he so that year
we got that on our own
Justin we got one and I say Brady get
hurt Brady gets hurt and you're like I'm
going to New England no England's
calling me before the game is over
did they really yeah I went to New
England I went to New England so they're
not healthy I'm gonna tell them that I'm
not ready to go but Matt castles there
right I'm in the facility I'm in the
room with tapes right after the uh you
know not the flight gave a spy gate and
I'm going I'm wandering tape so I'm
looking around like just being naive
stupid fanboy right whatever and being
silly but I'm
sitting there and I'm like damn I might
be on the New England Patriots I get
there I'm waiting up in the front
office's they tell me to go home yeah
they tell me to go home the GM is I'm
really blanking Scott Pioli thank you
holy crap I don't know what I did today
I haven't smoked pot in a while either
no back porch time maybe that's the
problem I think I need to go back to it
I think it's a few days up here where so
now I'm there but they burnt he brings
me in and he just goes who's he Yoli
really gonna get his name I go him to be
holy and he goes but listen we've we've
we've had a little mistake here he goes
I'm really sorry that we did this to you
he's like we brought you here with every
intention of you coming here and helping
us out I want you to know that we
apologize to the fullest
he's like Bill wants to come up here and
talk to you he might come up here in a
second just to say hi and whatever but
he goes what we're really scared of is
that matt cassel is unproven he's a
seventh round pick they're scared that
this is where I talk about framing the
team right they don't want me coming in
and the Boston fan base which was art I
was already getting a lot of Nona right
so I'm just going up to New England to
visit the Patriots they didn't want that
to be a distraction for the football
team
they had Matt Cassel he was their backup
they didn't want me looking over his
shoulder or him throwing five
incompletions everybody going oh they
should put Sims in and they sent me home
which was the right thing to do to build
a football team that was the right thing
to do they were smart cuz it it just
what a cost confusion and that team was
really good that year I mean that was
the team I want 11 at large the third
stringer behind castle Rohan Davey it
was it might have been so I don't even
remember look you can look it up 2008
roster of the New England Patriots I
can't remember who it is at that time so
yes
so all this time then I go to Kansas
City hold on before you to that you're
telling me never heard this but I've
never heard that before you're telling
me all of these years of people saying
that you're the Brady hater
you almost possibly could have replaced
Brady after the Bernard Pollard hit I
can't believe has never come up but yes
yeah that's Wow didn't that crazy
did belcheck ever come up nope never did
okay yep but he's busy it was Tuesday
yeah you're moving on I don't have time
to go well I'm just thinking that Scott
Pioli came up to break it down for you
and apologize yeah but then Jon Gruden
didn't say goodbye to you when you were
leaving the box I know the optics or did
you do they pay you when you go up on a
trip like that do they pay for your
flame yeah that's all taken care of
everything anything like that is is
nothing comes out of pocket quarterbacks
I have on this roster or Brady Matt
Cassel Matt Gutierrez Gutierrez that's
right they would rather have Matt
gutiere if castle went down this is the
same would have called me if Castle went
down you just come and play right bar
and maybe Gutierrez holds it down for a
week or whatever like that then you go
to Kansas City and you're throwing it's
not going anywhere it's not going
anywhere but I'm I'm beating the other
guys now I'm out there working out with
I'm not gonna name their names why
because I don't want to put it on that I
were you in Kansas City because that was
the year Brody Crowell got hurt early on
this is a this is the same season 2008
Brody Croyle from Alabama he is going to
be the guy there in Kansas City I think
he hurt his shoulder or something like
that so this is Todd Haley's team
this is Todd yeah this is Herm Edwards
firm Edwards - yes so you go there you
work out these guys and you're just I'm
not good but I'm better than them how
you been how bad is the ball coming out
like I can't throw a spiral I can't
throw a spiral but I can it's getting
there and I'm still talking a big game
and I'm you know whatever I'm trying to
be as confident as I can but I'm doing
enough to go these other two guys you
got here even with 70% Kristin's not as
good as me and they offer me a cocktail
from me 1.5 million dollars as soon as
the contract as soon as I got done with
the workout 1.5 and I have all like
stopped yeah Josh have you ever left a
room and if someone said you know I'd
like to offer you 1.5 million dollars
close but not not 1.5 okay so let's
let's all our listeners think Sims
football really bad beat out three other
guys who apparently threw it worse dead
ducks flying around ducks and they said
you know what we'd like to pay you 1.5
million dollars
and you responded I responded I promised
the Tennessee Titans I would go down
there which I had I said I would and
we've heard this I promised them now I
did I you know I messed one part of the
story up before I went to Kansas City I
went to Baltimore Oh with the Ravens
Ozzie Newsome sitting up on this
mezzanine level of the facility watching
from his chair the workout and this is
Joe Flacco's rookie year right 17th
picks and I can't even remember who the
starter was whatever but they're gonna
start Joe Flacco okay and um I'm what
I'm worried about in both these
situations I get done with Baltimore I
told I believe Eric decosta who's now
gonna be the GM to replace them I said
you don't want to sign me I'm not right
yeah and he's like he looked at me like
I had nine heads he's like I was like
you saw me out there I'm not right I was
like I got to tell you flat out because
I don't want you guys do expect to think
I'm gonna play this week and I'm gonna
let down ed Reed and right Lewis and
everybody in the world renames Troy
Smith
Todd Bauman and Joe Flacco right Bauman
is the one they signed okay because
instead of me and he worked out better
than me he legitimately worked out
better than me he desired Minnesota
right he should have been signed so that
was the right decision I don't know if
they were gonna sign me either way but
I'm just telling you what Baltimore I
said no then I go to Kansas City
Tennessee had been blowing me up and I
knew Tennessee loved me because when we
would go down there and play them in the
preseason I always played good and
Fischer used to like have fun and talk
[ __ ] with me during the game really ah
he I do a pic - Keith Bullock once and
like I'm in the next Drive going down
the field and it's like we're at the
10-yard line it's a TV timeout and he's
got like Bullock around he's like hey
since hey since he got you hey he's
talking about through which I love
because that's you know that's me that's
the kind of guy I am and I think I threw
my could no-look touchdown pass like two
plays later and I like looked at it was
a pump but he loved that crap but I
leave Kansas City I don't accept that
deal I go to the Titans they just think
I'm going to be good you've told us this
and that's where I signed the Patriots
part I did not know
yeah that's also yeah all right let us
go we're gonna get Braille that was
perfect I know sometimes I I said this
okay let's get this in before we go
we're gonna get your dad on a second
yeah don't talk about your wife really
quick oh yeah if you watch a show on
YouTube or the BR app you'll see that
there's one part where we have a little
gift of good fellows in there is Ray
Liotta and you come in and you look at
it and you go oh yeah by the way I
forgot to tell you well before you even
say it this falls in the category of
we've spent four years together sitting
in a room for hours and hours talking on
air and then more hours in other rooms
talking off the air and this has never
been discussed for years much like the
Patriots and you go Oh Ray Liotta my
wife went on a date with Ray Liotta what
right okay
all right strap everybody here we go so
I had bought my wife an engagement ring
um we're engaged to get married we're
down in Tampa I tell her I'm not ready
to get married you're already engaged
I'm engaged is the first time we're
engaged okay okay the first time because
there was two times so we're engaged I
go I'm not ready I'm still being a male
[ __ ] at that play that for lack of a
better phrase I'm just doing my singing
the wall testing the waters as they say
and I drink
she has Inklings of that and it's just
not right and I was like listen I'm
sorry I love you I want to marry you I
just know I'm not ready I've literally
never met someone as honest as you so
she she leaves I think I think she's
left the ring the ring is in the Box in
the room and I have taken the box now
and hid it somewhere because I'm like oh
I'm gonna leave while she packs up cuz
she's gonna yell at me and crying and
I'm just like I don't know what to do so
I'm a 23 year old kid at the time and I
just step out okay
and a few days go by and I go oh damn I
got that ring still I should go sell
that back to the jeweler I go into my
clout my clothes I die like buried it
under like 20 folded shirts and put it
like underneath one of oh you would
never know it's there but she found it
and I'm I'm literally walking out of the
door of my apartment
and I'm walking to the elevator and I
just go help me look at this ring and I
flip open the box there's no ring there
and I'm like what and I started calling
her and she wouldn't answer my calls or
anything and I think she texts me later
that night like yeah I took the ring and
sold it and used for a down payment in
the in New York City for an apartment
[Laughter]
then yeah a few weeks went by I didn't
know this so kind of after the back of
my friends were like dude you know like
you know you're your ex girl has gone on
the date or been out with Ray Ray Liotta
and I was like I didn't know oh my gosh
so nothing gets brought off of it but
she went on a date with Ray Liotta cuz
my wife's family owned a restaurant in
the theater district she used to work
there and I guess he was in there one
night and asked her out of the day and
your wife is a tower and my wife is
italian-style olds phil simms still sims
phil simms is uh well let's see we this
is mm mm no how old is he right now
oh he's six six okay that's how old ray
liotta is I know I know so your wife
went on a date with your dad basically
an Italian version of your dad actually
and funny how her dad heard that my
wife's debt my wife is still actually
kind of disturbed that her dad let him
go let her go out on the date with Ray
Liotta because he was in the restaurant
the night and saw her where did they go
so I don't know where they went we could
ask her we'll bring her on one did he
let her in the car and then she had to
reach over and open to her right me and
my wife we talked about things very
openly I mean you know me I'm extremely
Ray Liotta take her into the back of a
restaurant and walk every night
everybody
really fancied her and kissed her well I
I don't know I've asked I'm sure they
kissed I don't really know either way he
knew I had broken up with her in a bad
way and he actually offered to call the
paparazzi it did like make me feel worse
or like shove it in my face so he was
like hey we can get a lot may cost some
people to take some pictures of it you
know whatever however he talks but yes
so there you go that's incredible Karen
so we had carriage you flushed it down
the toilet
ran that's incredible yeah there you go
alright we gotta get you on the pike
yeah well ask your snoring ray liotta
she's in fro I would say Daniel does
need to come on because that's one of
the things like if we're talking about
someone I want them to be here to be
able to he's gonna hear this point in
the next week and be like and I'm gonna
go babe
I mean you want me to be big-time in
this business or what gotta be honest I
can't I can't be an actor sorry
alright I'm making an executive decision
we're just gonna figure it out we're
gonna have phil simms and JJ coming up
we need to talk about this the levy on
bail situation has not shown up yet all
the stories were don't worry he showing
up Wednesday we're recording this on
Wednesday and he has not shown up he
missed that meeting so much so that the
Steelers have come out and they've
released a lot of comments on this
general manager Kevin Cole Bert said he
was disappointed that he hasn't even
side to tender yet marques Pouncy was
the one that said Le'Veon Bell will be
there Wednesday we have always wanted a
franchise tag player to sit out ten
weeks play the final six it counts as a
season get a not a full year pay but get
a year of playing considered and then go
into the next year well rested this one
though I'm kind of rooting for him to
play I don't know because I want the
Steelers to be really good right how far
do you think this goes I don't I don't
know what to think about this I think
does it feel different than other times
it does feel different cuz I feel like
he wants to he's gonna do it at his own
rate and he just doesn't care about
anybody else which I do respect I want
him to go sign the tender that's the
first thing I want him to go sign it
go do it lock up the money and you can
find other ways to be a pain in the ass
and not play until you feel like you're
ready to go or in shape why do you want
him to sign the tender because I just
want to make sure he gets some money
they can still rescind it can't they am
I wrong about that I'm pretty sure they
can still resend the French
stack at this point he hasn't signed it
they could pull the Josh Norman on him
and then what has happened so what
happens if they but that he becomes a
free agent I believe there's no way that
happen oh he's got him by the balls
right so we talked ourselves out of that
I'm glad we talked through that yeah the
other thing is like hold none of the mic
no because I'm trying to play through
different scenarios in my head - yes he
can do week 10 he needs to show up
probably a few weeks before that just to
make sure they can put him on the exempt
list I think the two weeks - which would
screw him so he needs to show up at like
week seven or eight but if I was him
yeah what are you doing I'd show up
Saturday saturday Saturday I'd side
entender and obviously you're not gonna
play Sunday and I would make sure I take
my time and let them know I want to be
like full-speed football shape ready to
go before you put me on the field find
some sort of agreement like Odell
Beckham genndy Beckham do jr. did with
the New York Giants to where they can
come to an understanding of no you're
not just gonna throw me out there next
week all of a sudden to try to give me
the ball 70 times they seem even further
apart than ODI oh yes Odell the Giants
had seen like there was at least a
mutual respect that they could grow on
right this is multiple franchise tags in
a row a lot of feelings of disrespect
from Le'Veon Bell he came in out of
shape last year so I think they're
already worried about all right he
didn't come in out of shape it's just
hard to be it was a game shape right and
all the quotes I'm seeing out the last
two days yeah
James Connor is just as good our offense
is more than just one person the team
and you could speak to this seems to be
moving on from Le'Veon Bell because they
have to yes because Tomlin has to go we
need to play Sunday right the Browns are
a lot better than people are saying they
are miles Garrett is coming around the
edge and I need someone to block him
right this feels really weird feels
weird I have no feel for where this is
gonna go I have so my fantasy draft not
to make this personal I took James
Connor in the 14th round last night okay
i D end the owner of levy on bail and
said just to let you know I have James
Connor if you want him this is the
advantage of working for a bleacher
report he goes you know what do you hear
it a nice
I think you should trade for James
Connor so ah but I'm saying that ingest
cuz I want him to make me an offer
but at the same point this could go six
weeks I think there's a very real case
of it so we've we've talked on the
podcast about players wanting their
teammates to get paid and I remember a
couple weeks ago when Adele got paid and
we saw the video of Stirling Shepherd
going wild him in the locker room is it
any different for the Steelers where
they are a legit you picked them to win
the Super Bowl this year yeah our guys
looking around and being like damn he
needs to get in here and play and
they're wishing he was there they get it
but I do believe like some of the things
left Co said I think they believe that -
they're not just let me on bail you're
there you got a good offense they have
enough people to go around with Big Ben
and that offensive line that they can
make it work now they're not as
treacherous ago they did with DeAngelo
Williams exactly he was suspended and
James Connor certainly has the skillset
to fill that role he's not as good as
Le'Veon Bell of course and you know I've
told you about the Jalen samuel kid who
I like I think he'd be a similar sort of
fit there so they do and when you're out
of sight out of mind it's easier for the
players to go dim he hasn't been here
all TAS in all training camp so we can
focus with him not being here also let's
be realistic with this he can't get a
new deal it's not like Odell and Donald
and Matty where they bring him in and
sign right the franchise tags on the
table yes take it or leave it that's it
there's no negotiation poised right now
right now it's really just you trying to
show how petty you are yeah and look we
are the players podcast and I want to
stand up for them but I don't know why
I'm feeling different about this one
because it's almost football season and
you want all the best star players to be
out there and you want one of the best
teams best players to have it so there's
no other bullcrap experience so I need I
need you to help me make a decision yeah
am I rooting for levian
to sit out ten weeks and play the last
six and do what we've always said we've
always you've always asked for that I've
always asked for that and save your body
and remove the wear and tear or do I
want them back I want
what are we rooting I think we want more
of the first one I don't necessarily
we're gonna fully say he want levy on
bail to come back on his own accordance
he has no long term but uh you know
secure sure and yeah he's not gonna be
on the Steelers next she's not is that a
guarantee I would be shocked right
exactly right he needs to protect him so
that's all I'm rooting for is that he
takes it slow and takes it at his pace
and he does it the way he wants to do
because again if he was a piece of crap
third string running back or didn't live
up to his end of the bargain his ass
would had already been cut and on the
street so let's just not forget about
how do you express this to Steelers fans
who are gonna get furious as this keeps
going on yeah I would just say you still
have an awesome football team and the
Philadelphia Eagles won the Super Bowl
last year without the best player on
their team and the MVP of the NFL in my
opinion and you could still do that in
Pittsburgh if levy on Bell doesn't play
until week 11 or the Steeler still your
Super Bowl pick because they happen for
the playoff run but they don't have them
for the whole season I think I think
they are I'm going I'm going right or
not though I love makes the odds of the
Ravens winning the division yeah you
know what to torch the guy that has
Le'Veon I'm not trading you James Connor
I'm just gonna keep him because I think
he might have a pretty damn good I would
think his statue of a 14th round draft
pick if I do say myself seriously
seriously cuz he's gonna get a ton of
catches and he's gonna get carries so
yes uh I can't believe he's doing it I
know but it's happening yeah good for
him yeah man
I like Le'Veon I just I'm just saying in
person he's even more impressive than I
thought watching on film or on TV yeah
and as a person like just outside of the
the lines of the football field man he's
an awesome dude
I mean always smile on his face happy
could be like just happy-go-lucky kind
of guy I do love levy on bail oh this
one is perfect what do you have for me
nothing looking at you you're looking
with your mouth open
breath Sims in Lefko has a few staples
amendment number one Aaron Rodgers
amendment number three Kyle Shannon's
our favorite
- - what's three rice and beans well
means not beefy not beef
so this fits right into it David Johnson
and his wife Megan decided to ditch
animal products and start a vegan diet
after watching two documentaries on
Netflix last training camp what the
health and fork over nine yeah David
hated it they went vegan but guess what
he's no longer vegan because he wanted
to pack on pounds to get ready for this
season
do you read with that we agree with that
you vegan diet is not what NFL players
should be not especially not an NFL
running back he dropped 14 pounds in
less than two weeks last year and got to
as low as 210 I'm sure as hell not gonna
say that's the reason his wrist was
broken yeah but was it well maybe he's a
little frail it's official iron yeah
maybe you can't you gotta be the running
back position the physical grind I'm not
telling anybody just to be vegan I there
are certain people and body types and
blood types in the world that need meat
our big thing behind that just so we can
re-educate some of the people who've
been listening is we don't need to be
the greatest carnivores that the
planet's ever seen I mean America right
now we've been like oh I gotta have a
pig for breakfast
I gotta have a another cow for lunch and
then I gotta have a cow for dinner I'm
treated as an American I can't [ __ ]
take it anymore I want a chicken ass
just put some bacon on that cow - I want
double yeah flank steak right I don't
know why my belly's so big I don't get
it I'm doing Atkins diet David because
you have nine pounds of sludge in your
stomach your body can't get the meat out
now even David Johnson did say though
that after stopping going vegan meat
tasted so good quote I think I ate meat
like four days in a row steaks burgers I
thought I think I went on a binge which
I felt afterwards but it felt great
eating meat yeah well yes it is amazing
cuz I like a lot of weeks don't eat red
meat until like Friday night yeah and
man when I cut into that steak holy crap
I told you I had a bacon burger right
after I went vegan for 31 days it was
the single greatest me
my entire life it just like hits that
part of your body where you're like
endorphins or certain vitamins and
nutrients that need to be taken out of
there especially like I'm a blood to a
type-o blood type okay and they're
supposed to be hunters and gatherers
where it's Ludd oh is a hunter and a
gatherer a hunter gatherers that's right
basically when you get to the basic
premises look it up tight I'm learning a
whole lot about you yeah wait where we
going buddy that a hunter-gatherer there
needs to be some meat in the diet it's
kind of like yeah you're not kidding I
just looked it up was it safe I mean you
guys think I just come out here and just
go sometimes yeah I mean the blood type
diet are you a hunter or a farmer I'm
reading an article yeah blood type Oh
first to evolve in around 50,000 BC is
associated with our hunter-gatherer days
when we survived primarily on meat
because of this typos are prescribed a
high-protein low-carb diet free of dairy
wheat and grains you're psycho I know a
lot about a little that's all I could
say diet a lot about government and
football I know a lot about a little
like I know I know a little about a lot
is that I should say I know a little
tidbit about this and that all over the
place yes I only know a lot about like
two things what are the other than
football what is it I guess diet nice
that's it
Tom Brady just came out and said he'd
like to play five more years okay
is he capable I don't think so I mean
we'll see I mean he's certainly proving
us all wrong at this point my big thing
with Tom Brady actually had to talk
about this up in the New England rsn
last night cuz they were attacking me
that I had Russell Wilson ahead of Tom
Brady oh gosh I am some NBC does this to
you now because they're putting out
articles every day with your quarterback
ranking right and then they just feature
the wolves and put you on TV me and they
fed me to Boston and Boston they were
just like they just couldn't help it
Thank You Super Bowl versus five I mean
is all the same I think what really it
comes down to is Boston is insulting
Russell Wilson because if you're gonna
react like Tom Brady's that much better
than Russell Wilson let's put on the
game film from last year and see what
Russell Wilson has to do
and then see what Tom Brady has to do
you should flip it Tom Brady in the
preseason game against the Eagles they
were like wow he's ready to go it was
three-step drops and out Russell Wilson
is running around with no offensive line
no coaches he's number two wide receiver
from last year was waved the Patriots
picked him up for a day and caught him
the same day that he went listen you're
not even gonna have a chance to practice
with the team you should get out of here
the the in it's more insulting to
Russell Wilson I just say that they
shouldn't be compared that I kind of
said that I just was like I went through
the whole offensive coordinator thing
the offensive lion thing all of that the
my big thing with Brady when we know
it's gonna be slipping is just when he's
not wanting to take hits that's that's
the number-one thing all starts turning
the Eli Manning could kind of that way
right right
well yeah I know yeah that's what it is
that is definitely one of utilize demos
and I saw it in the preseason a few
times for me like other thing that
happened over the weekend and since we
didn't get to do the Monday podcast was
a reaction to the story that the whoa
big offseason not player of the of the
offseason but the guy that we thought
you were gonna pick Davis Webb was
released yes all the binders all of the
music playlist him getting back to the
cowboy buthow sins of pages printed in a
giant suit so many notes of Eli Manning
he single-handedly got a printer in the
facility so that he could print more
pages his arm was not just strong some
would argue it was too strong too strong
yes waved and everybody went we actually
had someone on reddit say maybe this is
the reason that Chris Sims didn't make
him the whoa big offseason Player of the
offseason because he knew he was gonna
get wave I did not I did not know that
but I know with the way he was
approaching his offseason I could tell
you this is what I knew no coaching
staff was looking at Davis Webb going oh
wow that's a I mean the he that's like
the kiss of death when oh the this
self-promotion tour from the guy who's
unproven and you know coming
saying he's mad at Ben McAdoo and like
when coaches hear that and you haven't
done anything in the league I mean that
you're almost blacklisted that
especially with the team you're on for
that point they're just like damned is
this guy really cuz he's out of reality
here what the hell is wrong with him I
still can't believe he said my arms so
strong it's almost too strong I just
want to say to all the people out there
who write when Davis Webb got cut
started tweeting at us immediately I
mean like that's how I found out I just
went on Twitter and I had 15 tweets and
10 DMS from people being like the dragon
is done what's he gonna do that's
awesome
everyone should keep doing that
throughout the entire NFL season it's
great guys are another one of those
teams to were that I would like to point
out that if the starting quarterback
goes down the euro is in trouble it's
over like this Panthers it's just stupid
I don't even know what they're doing
what about the people that are saying
WOW you you kind of sold us that Davis
Webb was the quarterback of the future
you took a running back at pic number 2
albeit possibly a generational running
back right and right now Darnell's able
to start right away
Josh Allen's had the tools to little
fans one of both ways right now Eli Eli
deserves more of a chance but yet they
want the franchise quarterback and say
Kwan Barkley I'm sick of hearing it I'm
a Giants fan so yeah I mean if you got a
problem with it and then the streets of
New York come up and talk to me with it
cuz it it's annoying to hear it I mean
that you hear that New York yeah just
get him they wanted always they wanted
sake one they want Eli to finish on a
good note and they want the quarterback
of the future that's what we wanted I
mean no and first of all the quarterback
of the future thing let's just see where
it goes with Sam darling everybody and
all these guys in the draft first of all
there's more guys that are talented
coming out this year so it's just I
wouldn't be worried about it they made a
decision to go in all in on the Eli
Manning for the next year to two and
they got a running back that I mean I
think is the most talented guy to come
out in the draft since Adrian Peterson
hey guys remember I told you about that
Yahoo mobile app did you get it yet
Yahoo Sports mobile app are you ready
for live football on your phone well
with the Yahoo Sports mobile app you get
live local and primetime NFL games all
season long never miss that local game
never miss that big national matchup all
you need is the
who sports app seriously go get the app
it's your ticket to watching live NFL
games wherever you want it's all
football and it's all yours watch live
and if L game's on the Yahoo Sports
mobile app what do you give that one one
out of ten that one felt better than the
last one yeah I've been strong I mean
I'd like a little ad lib in there
something I did if you saw the script
changed a few years to that so we're
about to get Jay Ajayi on here when he
got traded from the Dolphins to the
Eagles that was kind of when everyone
went oh crap Eagles are going for the
run right next game they played Denver
busted out that huge touchdown run and
that was sort of like that and then it
was like wow this is exciting that's the
dream right
you get traded from a team that's not
doing well to a team that eventually
wins the Super Bowl I mean that is the
jackpot especially a team that like it
sounds like he had a lot of like bent
like pent-up issues there with my yeah
and then you yeah you go to a place
where all of a sudden you feel
appreciated you know what was it going
into last season there was they could
point that but whether Jaya Jaya was
gonna be the starter on the roster and
things like that because Kenyan Drake
was there and all that it's special I've
got a few things I want to ask jjai am
I'm interested to talk to him I'm
burping me I'm most excited for when he
joins us is simply as accent it is gonna
be crazy to hear NFL football player
talk that way in a British accent yes
it's very odd are they just gonna use
him as the advocate for the London games
all the time do you think when people
interview Jaya Jaya they ask him about
is there a big fan base of the I bet you
there I bet you get to ask that all the
time all the time he represents all of
Britain what part of England's he from
look at them fifty gelsen you are even
where he's from
I'm supposed to note see you should say
that as a professional I should know
that not as an Eagles fan but we're
about to get him on he's called oh gosh
I'm so nervous I just see London he's a
Nigerian moved to Maryland Jay a je six
feet tall 223 pounds all rolling
bumble bowling ball from Boise State
bumbling rolling taken in the fifth
round and far exceeded expectations thus
far in the NFL has amassed more than
2,300 rushing yards 10 touchdowns are
receiving touchdown and a ring as a
Superbowl champion
are you just a Super Bowl champs all
year long or yeah what up J hey there's
that boys you can't be a big scary
running back sorry we're silly
yeah we're silly we're ridiculous no
feel that's when you get the real JJ
yeah yeah that's right I want no piece
of you on the field I can promise that
promise you that I played quarterback in
the NFL for a little while I don't know
if you know that nope at all all right
two things first of all right off the
bat left go hear that I'm sitting next
to is a huge Eagles fan huge I mean he
he's a super fan boy loves you when you
got traded from the Dolphins last year
oh my gosh oh gosh the Eagles are going
we're gonna win the Superbowl now and
you delivered and now I have to hear his
big mouth for the rest of the year
thanks jack nah I guess everything
worked out for me
so I'm I was lucky enough that you know
I got a Super Bowl out of that deal
that's the dream right like I was just
saying this before you came on you go
from a team that it seemed like it
wasn't going great and you go to a team
that's first place in the entire
conference and you're like wow I get is
it do you still pinch yourself that that
actually happened you know I did some
time with remembering the season and how
it went so I appreciate how everything
ended up working out for me
obviously it was some ups and downs
there but for it to end up how it did I
think you're a special way now
you know cherish that part of my legacy
it's it's incredible I mean there's a
perfect ending so but what I would like
to know just like the history and I mean
of course you we alluded to you being
born in London England was football a
sport as a young boy when you moved over
here that you knew something about or
ever you just totally soccer and kind of
learned it as you as you got here yeah I
mean once I moved up here you know I was
still playing you know soccer when I was
young but I got introduced to football
like by accident because I didn't know
anything my family didn't and then
basically just as I started to play you
know I learned on the fly and then my
family started to learn as well and then
my brother started to play and it just
trickled down so now we know all about
it now we do know all about it I'm kind
of like interested in that that career
art just because okay so your parents
what did they say about you playing
football at first what positions that
you were you always the running back
growing up and who were the players as
you were living here in America and in
Maryland I believe at the time were you
kind of looking up to or were your idols
as you were a young man yeah living in
Texas and you know my parents don't
think they cared that I was playing
they're probably happy that I was doing
something active enough you know getting
in trouble right and that was always
running around anyway
so it was like good probably a good
release and I always played running back
because I mean I was just like the most
natural position I guess for me to learn
just you run away from people and right
people mesh because I was always just
playing it good at tag and stuff like
that so yeah I mean it was cool as as uh
you know I was able to learn more about
the game and everything you know for my
send up an anecdote pretty cool thought
is it's awesome
alright so I'm the huge fan I was up
there in Minnesota losing my mind
I was also at the parade losing my mind
the parade you know to see that amount
of people
what was that day like for you yeah I
think that was just a great moment for
Ferry in just a great moment for me as
well just to see something like that and
see how it affected so many people so it
was just an awesome experience and down
you know something that I'll remember
trying we're trying to do it again and I
decided that for me as soon as the ball
gets kicked off against Atlanta that's
when I'm putting away the Super Bowl and
I'm going alright I'm excited for this
year's team I feel like you guys have
already done that yeah I mean after you
can't rest on what happened last year in
ourselves and we're already back at it
tomorrow so I mean I think mystically
put it to bed early this summer after
the ring ceremony man it's on to this
year how does this team I guess in terms
of the energy because it's so hard to
repeat you have Carson you have Nick
they've both been perfect in this whole
situation
Doug is gonna be Doug you still got guys
like Jason Peters you still got guys
like Malcolm Jenkins and you have guys
like Chris Long who have kind of been
through it already what is the big
message that you're saying to each other
or they're saying to you guys to keep
that focus right now what's that message
been I mean we just got a identity issue
year this year I'll just lose one's
gonna put last year and in our face and
everything but you know last year was
last year just a new year different
things were gonna happen this um you
have to be able to react and come ball
push through whatever comes while
rolling executing and be great the the
banner in the locker room I mean that
was a I know Malcolm Jenkins said he
wanted to take the Super Bowl banner
the locker room was that like a did
everybody on the team agree with that I
mean kind of it to what you're saying
just like get that crap out of here we
don't need to hear about it anymore
yeah I don't even think I saw the banner
boy I mean if cap if Jake you know
captain Jake says they gotta go down
then I started there captain
captain Jang that's his name I like that
I like cap Jake
all right so jump Jay we appreciate
coming on I know you're doing a lot of
stuff with Marriott right now what do
you got going on yeah pretty cool deal
we've got going on you know we're
looking all year so fine you know these
passionate fans out here about just love
the game of football and love to travel
as well you know what the opportunity to
get to travel and you get that
opportunity by you know going to quote
your correspondence website or going to
the booth out here in Philly and you
know doing a video and basically if you
get the opportunity to win get a chance
to go to London my hometown and watch
the game out there also get to go to
Mexico City which will be probably a
great time and finally the Super Bowl so
it's a pretty cool thing and hopefully
we can get some really cool videos on
the competition you know stops pretty
cool thing that Marriott's doing this is
one other thing I have to ask you okay
you being from London and soccer being
such a big deal over there James has a
theory I have a theory
I'm a little crazy but you won't be the
first person to affirm that if you hear
me out here I think that if the NFL
players I think the NFL we have the
greatest athletes in the world and I
think if we took maybe not even some in
the NFL but if we took our best athletes
here in America some of the guys you've
played against right let's say we had
you at center and you had Odell Beckham
jr. right wing and Jalen Ramsay at left
wing and maybe LeBron at goal I always
say that if these group of athletes that
I'm talking about right now if they
played soccer from the
age of nine up that we would dominate
soccer in the world scope of things I
would love to hear you either say yes
Chris you're right or totally crap on me
and feel free I mean the only reason I
would say that there's a good
possibility that that could be right is
maybe because there's a lot of you know
immigrants from other countries that
come to the US and learning football you
know cuz it's such a big melting pot
here they'll get a lot of talent from
other countries similar to like how you
look at a front-row Cup team and how I
love their changed in their the whole
squad was immigrants you know to front
you know I'm trying server right I know
I agree I think that's what my point is
though so yeah go ahead I don't know
what's keep going now I'm just saying
I'll be interesting to see obviously you
know I think the main thing is if it was
the main sport like you said compared to
football baseball basketball you know
you lose all those elite players and
physical guards right the same country
so kids and finesse caring you know yeah
you got the bootstrap to it but it's oh
you mean I'm touching coordination as
well so yeah I know all right all right
I think I'm gonna take that as you're
right guys I'm just letting you know
sorry JJ agrees with Chris saves put it
in the police report official Jay you're
the man good luck kick the Falcons ass
you're the man love you have a great day
haha shake you guys be good man have a
good day okay i mean he laughed he
thought it was funny he's cute i I
wanted to ask him who his favorite
soccer team was but cap [ __ ] always
Arsenal I have it right here cop Jake
thinks that we should take it down I'm
now also there's a lot of people that
have brute strength I love the phrase
brute brute strength
it's a finesse game I was ready for the
accent but it
throw me for a loop he's so calm earth
is so timid right Annie is is nice he's
very nice nice no and brute strength cap
Jake set to take down the the banner I
think he agree didn't either
I liked it I thought he did say he was
kind of like look look at France they're
filled with like Nigeria migrants yeah
like it's amazing yes it was amazing at
JJ himself we say is from London his
parents are from Nigeria yes but I don't
know I don't know how many people these
are gonna agree with you very
soft-spoken yes very quiet concise to
the point you're veering into Australian
there it always does and it'll
eventually become Rick Pitino all my
accents eventually come Rick Pitino do
you think Jay Ajayi is the starter all
year long do you think Corey Clement
ends up replacing him how much of a role
does Darren Sproles play this year yeah
I mean the Darren Sproles thing is
certainly the where is he at right now
health-wise aja I I still worry about a
giant knee you know that yeah it's weird
to look at it doesn't seem like it's
right layers out I do think I think
Corey Clements the guy I think I do too
I mean I know you were on him early last
year and you were correct I mean he's
he's got the right you know I are you
saying yes got a great builder run with
power and then Yeti he's got those hands
like you yes yes and you know what else
really attractive is he handsome guy let
me show you a picture okay this live on
the air Sims has a theory that
attractive players and I use the word
handsome he's using attractive but it's
okay I think Corey Clement is kind of a
looker yeah he's he's handsome guy I
agree yet he would fit the mold he video
of him I'm like wow he's and he's got a
good look he dresses well yeah I think
he naturally has star quality written
about him III said this but in the
beginning of last year I said I think
Corey Clements gonna be the hidden star
I didn't get him in fantasy but I would
take him in around 910 it's hard just
because you guys are so you guys are
like you guys have kind of become be New
England with their running back by
committee according to the down and
distance situation Matt people on the
family a match with Al Sean Jeffrey hurt
right now yeah Mac Hollins is banged up
yes the starting 3 wide receiver
for the Eagles our Nelson Aguilar at the
one right who's this Mike Wallace at the
two mhm and currently fifth round pick
from two years ago Shelton Gibson at the
three yeah Zach Ertz is the best
receiver on this team as Michael
Kendrick said on Hard Knocks before he
was ceremoniously cutters insider
trading they just put Richard Rodgers on
the IR which i think is a killer but
it's Dallas Goddard is like the three I
know and that I wonder how much of a
role my man DeAndre Carter will play
yeah I think he's gonna be up I would
imagine that he gets in the slot makes
it so I mean Carter I forget is like a
26 27 year old that was originally on
the the Ravens he was the Ravens but
he's gonna practice squad there yes yes
yeah so it's uh you guys will be okay
you're not like lack of weapons
altogether but I always say this very
team that runs a lot of 12 and 21 yeah
you do there's gonna be two tight ends
or two running backs on the field most
snaps yeah and if it's Sproles or Corey
Clement they can all catch the ball
again if it's if it's Dallas Goddard and
Zach Ertz vacant block and catch the
ball those are the formations they like
to run out of and I think it'll be a lot
of single sets with Nelson a galore as
the one ride receiver that's what I see
them do yeah I think you're right I
think that's gonna be I think what I've
seen from the offensive line early I'd
like more tight ends and running backs
on the field anyway yeah I hear you
alright so that was Jay Ajayi or as my
dad used to call him Jo JG let's get a
phil simms on the line that's called the
big [ __ ] what's up nothin man
nothing's up you guys are late as usual
but that's what I expect that's right
we're media moguls we have we have
things we're doing yeah Phil we have a
new show buddy yes okay I know you're a
is uh my old coach would say you think
your star yeah I'm a star so that's Bill
Parcells slash Al Davis slash
quarterback he almost would imitate Al
Davis of course he loved Al Davis and
learned a lot from him was helped out by
hymns and so we honed Phil so what we're
doing I'd actually like to collect a
but a press from you you know when like
a new movie comes out and there's a
times Chris movies I've ever seen
Phil can you just like give us our show
a compliment even though you haven't
seen it and we'll just use it as like
Phil Simms says oh man you two are is
funny watching you as you are on the
radio nice okay that's good it's on the
podcast on a radio but it's okay don't
worry whatever I said okay radio same
thing to me come on you know I and I did
yes I watched a lot of it my wife of
course she has to watch everything her
son Christopher does oh yeah I've seen
this you haven't seen this new show yet
no dad no it comes out tonight's the
debut last night last night
butch because this is coming out on
Thursday morning we're gonna show it to
you but last night it came out and
you'll get to see it okay I will watch
it and I'll critique it and then blister
it next week sounds good I like that I
think I maybe I was she was showing me
or I was listening to you guys the other
day or whatever it was you were killing
Davis Webb oh that's what we do he has
an arm dad that's it's too strong so
strong it may be too strong yes yes I'm
too good and let me do another press
conference and just practice squad but
I'm gonna oh my god I know that's what
unwritten rule in the NFL and what is
that son if you're not doing [ __ ] on the
field shut your mouth
yes that's pretty close so we do the
backup quarterback what do we want to
hear from you nothing nothing this that
is right when can I have the quarterback
you don't talk to the press you don't
hold a press conference yeah whatever
yeah no I don't know they're there for a
week and look I don't mean to get on
David's web too much here but it did
bother me there for a while went man
what has he got like a PR guy it's
everyday in one slab he's on the cover
oh it was incredible we literally had of
a segment called whoa big offseason from
him because it was every day and I do I
didn't even mean to go down this this
row but
like little things like that I was just
saying to left go on the podcast will
not buy him the benefit of the doubt
when it comes time to go who do we want
to keep him or this guy like you're not
gonna be seen as a or in favor with the
coaching staff when they know you're
that type of guy during the offseason
and don't you agree with that yes you
guys made a great point you just said
I'm working in the offseason I'm gonna
go see this guy I'm doing it yeah okay I
don't need to know that I mean that's
your damn job exactly you know I just
can't imagine what I've been doing well
I got up this morning on social media if
it was there when I was playing and I
ran three miles came home took a nap
then him worked went down and worked out
ran did this then threw the football and
I'm gonna meet with my guys this weekend
because we're gonna do it on our own to
get team chemistry and really get our
timing down you know this timing down
with receivers there made me one of the
most overused phrases and history real
we got we got to get our timing down
well what the hell what timing is it you
know after a few throws I got it man I
see oh you're gonna make the out cut
there it is I don't know yeah maybe I
plated it well we didn't play in a
different time you did but it hasn't
change that much where Oh guys timing
you know just I'm not used to him yet
and what do you mean I tell you what I
could get used to Odell Beckham jr.
about three seconds okay no no we
totally oh my god we're gonna work on
our timing and we're gonna start in
April but we're you know we're gonna
hold it somewhere and we're gonna let
everybody the world know we're doing it
because you know that's what we do well
how about somebody do it and not talk
about it yeah I know all right
yeah I was a good man that was a good
man off your chest
that was so your left coast third
favorite guest of the day just so you
know dad because yeah because he's had
we had Brian Dawkins on earlier and I
mean that he loves Brian Dawkins you
know Brian Dawkins is Hall of Famer and
you know and if you're an eagle lover
you know he was always somebody to root
for and so good yeah and then be a joga
you know I think I have phil above
okay good I just wanted to make sure I
thought anybody to the Eagles maybe went
ahead and no similar my second how's he
doing how's he feeling and what's going
on he seemed good he's very British
he's very British I did not know that
yeah he comes on he goes he goes you
know you know when I was younger played
soccer and then I moved to Texas they
threw me off I can't even lie oh my gosh
no that I never really had a chance to
talk to him and any times we when I was
doing games and anything like that
no I was really asked a question because
these bangs I've heard that he's having
a little knee problems and stuff like
that Phil you know when players come on
the Sims aleph go podcast they disclose
all of their injuries they really could
you tell me about all right so this is
what we want we want from you what we we
want this so here's our student what I
want from you what payback payback for
what yeah
cash he's gonna hold this back game and
debt over to me Adam
you know we teach him he lies so much I
said no you don't want to play for money
yet and already I could do it okay so
he's just you know I'll go you know you
double the cube I'll play and I'll go
man you're so stupid
now you're just relying on nothing but
pure luck yeah you know whatever so his
thing is now all right let's start from
scratch right and we'll pay up soon it's
over yeah no we're not doing that yes
you took advantage of your son when he
was still learning the game what you
said that we played that day I said man
I should have made you you lost like
another $1,200 so we're gonna make it
quick we're doing Super Bowl predictions
we've done this already already left Co
can I tell them you sure all right so my
Super Bowl prediction yeah is Aaron
Rodgers and the Green Bay Packers facing
deshaun Watson in the Houston Texans I
mean you are really reaching out I think
both are reaches I have the Packers
winning okay why are the Packer
what on defense is gonna make you think
they can do it well I believe in the
three-headed monster they have up front
of Kenny Clark Mike Daniels and Mohammed
Wilkerson Mohammed season I have and you
know it's funny I feel like he's back to
his old days when I do man you and I are
watching different tapes you know yeah
well you're still watching from
Blockbuster I like oh man you know
finally I'm gonna talk one up for you it
took in only two years but you finally
got one on the board good okay yes go
ahead
I like I trust Mike I find Mike Patton's
defense to be a lot more sound than
great
there you go and I also say that they've
added a lot of young athletes to the
back hit they hit gold I think and three
people again
Alexander and songs and Josh Jackson and
I'll tell you who else I like I like the
middle linebacker they picked two yes I
said wow they got some speed inside
which I think you know I'm big on that
you need your linebackers they're gonna
have one linebacker in the middle that's
really fast my big point is Phil I think
Rogers is the MVP this year I think he
comes back ready to ball and I think he
just has a special year I think that
Texans have a very special potential for
their defense with all the guys they
have the clown ease and it they all be
healthy and that's big if I just watch
my Eagles win the Super Bowl with Nick
Foles a backup left tackle and Holly Poe
leave a levite I know middle linebacker
they're fine anyway here's your son's
Super Bowl prediction okay all right so
I'm going New Orleans Saints versus the
Pittsburgh Steelers and I'm choosing
this dealers to win it all okay yeah
here's what I'm gonna say a couple
things first
yeah I'm gonna take Phillip Rivers to be
the MVP of the NFL this year okay for
the first time ever he might have an
offensive line that's not going to be
destroyed before the first game of the
season right well I think they're gonna
make it now son he's not here yet they
can still have this happen in prac
this it's got the best receiving court
in the NFL they're not going to be able
to hold other teams down to like zero
points I think you could still run on
their defenses to that so he's gonna get
to throw it and my man's good he's not
even throwing a sidearm anymore he's
down there man he's he's a tenth to Kobe
remember him the Trent what ever held to
call me you said almost throw it
underhanded for the Pittsburgh Pirates I
think but whatever I'm taking the Saints
to be in the Super Bowl okay and I think
let's see I had on beating the Rams at a
championship game I got to remember
these things because I did it on
Showtime someone stay with them yeah
then I'm taking the Patriots to be
Jacksonville in the MC Jimmy J
championship and I'm taking the Saints
to one at all okay so you're gonna go
Saints Patriots and nature and the
Saints are gonna well I like that that
that I'm gonna tell you I listen the
Saints every sketch I've been looking
over scared so I just go come on this is
stupid
tell every schedules hard hey yeah it's
professionally in the NFC I like it you
know you did it this morning
Christopher's right see I am watching
and critiquing and going why did he say
that stupid-ass thing but that's a
different story but but you know you
look at schedules you just go man you
just can't predict we don't know Kansas
City the Chargers Kansas City can do a
couple things they're loaded on offense
the quarterback scares anybody their
defense doing this they have a chance to
score points and make it happen they can
block I think the Chargers got players
but on the other side can Kansas City
slow down the charger offense at all
I can't imagine no I mean my god I you
know well whatever so yeah I know I know
there's our picks and so yeah I know
there's a lot of great things just like
Chicago who I mean all of a sudden I
look at their roster didn't go it's
amazing what one guy did to it and how I
view everything else differently which
is so true and Christopher and I I think
we I don't know if I talked to you about
that we did Vic Fangio yes you know is
going to use him and you know what
coaches do is I always say really good
players
Khalil max a really good player is he
great no he's not great yet because he's
got to do it longer but really good
players with a really good coach become
superstars yes right and that's what I'm
anxious to see and it wouldn't shock me
as we sit here and we talk that Chicago
Bears they could do anything they could
win that division yeah as easy as they
finish fourth right so yeah I hear you
there I mean I look at that division
with uh I mean with the Bears especially
is that you're talking about that I mean
that front seven deck as a chance to be
49ers esque
in the Harbaugh Vic Fangio days right
because I just look at like ro Quan
Smith and go that could be Patrick
Willis
oh okay Khalil Maccabee Alden Smith and
then you got the praying mantis let
Leonard Floyd on the other side so if
there's some you know that let alone
Eddie Goldman and Hakeem Hicks and that
would be my big if right you know inside
are they gonna get you know UNIX is a
baller you stop the run but also you
don't like I did any travail thought in
there yeah yeah I mean hey listen hey
yeah listen he's a player this is nice
he's big-time he does it all and I don't
know last year when I watched Chicago
play he hadn't lost anything
and the Bears you know they were a pain
in the butt to everybody they except for
maybe a game or two yes now they got
some guys that can go win the game yes
they do
so there you go Sims enough go faithful
you've been waiting for the pics and
they're now in Chris Sims has Steelers
over Saints Adam Lefko has you betcha
Packers over Texans and the big man big
Phil Simms has weighed in his MVP is
Philip Rivers and his Super Bowl is the
Saints over the Patriots Phil would you
like to before you leave and before we
sign out say anything to the homies the
fans of Sims and left go to corny white
guys doing a show that was the perfect
way to sign out Thank You Daniel you the
man see ya he was
he was because he's he got to do a radio
tour tour and yet he's wrapped up I mean
like he's got the blockbuster one oh
that was great you legit lied it's fine
I got my first one and now it's gonna
come like a water [ __ ] bill yeah
all right pendrick has left to go do
work stuff thank you so much to
everybody for listening again if you
guys could go to youtube and check out
the new Sims and left go show this is
the podcast that is the show Wednesdays
at 8:00 p.m. this episode we had Arnold
Tony Romo Marcus Peters tio and
Ochocinco Phil said he said I have saw
it already I saw the show he saw
Instagram last week with you and I he's
like that most via shows exactly do what
Phil didn't do and watch the show we'd
appreciate it we will have our pick show
tomorrow right here wherever you listen
to podcast whether that's iTunes whether
that's Spotify or however you listen to
it and we will pick every game me and
Sims will start our competition for the
fifth straight year to see if Sims could
finally get a victory here we go baby
the dreaded left go this is the year for
Sims peace out homies Fenric would say
good evening and the lef koe man says ha
ha ha ha ha ha ha ha at you tomorrow see
you guys